wenn wir uns überlegen Frau Illner und
da und da kriege ich Puls das ein
Verteidigungsminister erstmals in der
Geschichte dieses Landes sich öffentlich
in ein fraktionsveranstaltung stellt und
sagt wir sind im Blick unsere Aufgaben
der Landes- und Bündnis für nicht
verteidigungsfähig wenn er sagt ich
brauche 10 Milliarden mehr für den
verteidigungshaus ist durch deklinieren
kann für was in jedem Cent braucht und
ich erlebe jetzt in den Verhandlungen
dass man ihn abspeisen will mit zwei
Milliarden dann wird diese zeitenwände
verhungern die Olaf Scholz angesprochen
hat und deswegen noch mal meine
Aufforderung bitte Lars Klingbeil alles
sind die Waagschale zu werden im
Kriegszeiten ist ein
Verteidigungsminister von enormer
Bedeutung ihn zu unterstützen sonst wird
das nichts mit der Zeit wenn du unfähig
verlieren wieder vertrauen wie nach 2014
wo wir schon mal von zwei Prozent und
viel mehr gesprochen haben